[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have a very exciting show today
we are gonna be talking about who would
you write and when we're talking about
the last letter project we have a very
special guest we have Andy trail of
joining us hello nice to be here thank
you for coming on to the show greatly
appreciate it much appreciate and it was
so cool that you came in with Jill
Hudson yeah ghosted last week and then
here you are now on the show because
that's what happens you have really
great people that get to meet that way
and I'm very blessed to have had the
last letter fall into my life and I'm
super excited to talk about it on the
show today
I'm excited your your history is crazy
when you were telling me about this I
think it's important for us to you know
unpack it we have really cool images to
talk about this as we go through the
whole essence of who would you write is
just crazy so let's yeah let's dig into
this let's get to it
we have a cool picture of you and your
mother yes to start us off so tell us
about the story in the book that you
authored along the journey
yeah that's mom and dad mom and dad so I
had the kind of the typical family story
with one loving and one not as loving so
dad was pretty pretty rough he was
bipolar and I don't know how many things
he might have been diagnosed with but it
was not easy in the house so basically
from a young age I lived in a lot of
fear and mom was loving right it was
interesting cuz mom was Catholic and dad
was Jewish so there was already tension
in the family even before we were born
both families disowned the other so it
took them the ticket have grandkids in
order to welcome them back in so there
was a lot of tension to begin with but
yeah that that was that was them and
that was sort of my childhood a lot of
dependency on mom for security yes
yes yeah and it's this is a really
important thing to mention just because
everyone has these different sort of
situations that they grow up in yeah you
have either so it's very rare that you
have a mom and dad that are just
absolutely blissed-out and that like
totally loving your childhood stuff yes
sometimes it's a divorce sometimes it's
a the religious kerfuffle sometimes it's
one is abusive like you know we've
talked about that I know so much and
it's just like and family is just a
messed up yeah and the beauty is is that
we all project that oh we're the only
one were the only ones that had Adams oh
yeah everyone else had it so good
no I deserved every beat and I got man
and Ron Ron turned out he turned out
well thank you I've actually found
interestingly enough the people that
have had to overcome the most like
traumatic experiences are often the
richest people to be with in their older
age because they kind of have to find a
degree of peace with all of it and so
yeah I've certainly found that being
around people that have gone through
trauma and then sort of come out the
back and are really incredible people to
be around you know yeah and the ones
that haven't that's why I'm taking this
journey that I'm now on to sort of reach
out and share some love and you know
take them to the light side if possible
maybe we can have a session I'd love you
Ronnie break this into session I
recently learned the term unintegrated
trauma so whatever we experienced when
we were young and even when we're adults
we have to figure out how to integrate
it into our lives and into our just
well-being on a day-to-day basis and
when it's not integrated it can really
lead to some really painful sort of
neurosis or psychosis and just just
issues that we face so
integrating it is insanely important so
okay so let's continue because this this
was going on for you until you were 18
and then as you left well I mean mom and
dad divorced when I was 10 okay but the
drama stayed on for ad infinitum but I
mean the story because the the story if
we go to really the story of leading
into the the impetus for the book was
very much tied to my relationship with
my mom yes because when we got divorced
you know how the shuffle works the kids
go to one side of the other side and I
went to mom side and you know every time
I talk to dad there always be some you
know issue issue yeah there's always one
of us there I have to I'm the youngest
of the three of us so I'm the baby thank
God that I got like I didn't have all
the the difficulties of the older one
but what happened was was that that one
of us I think this happens to families
pretty regularly there was already
always one of us that was in the penalty
box
so it was like I'm not talking to dad
for the next three years I'm not talking
to that so that was basically our lives
but there's always one of us was in the
penalty box eBooks
yeah and and the other two had to you
know deal with the drama of talking to
one or the other and it was never really
that easy and yeah I went I the story
for me where it really you know shifted
my life was going to college yes so tell
us about this yeah so when I when I went
to college as a freshman I was really
yeah I I don't know what I was thinking
but I decided to do a sociology of death
class it was no actually do know what I
was thinking I was I was scared to death
of death and then you took and that's so
interesting that taking the class also
was a deep part of what ended up
happening at the time is crazy yeah
because the thirteen or fourteen I'd
wake up in the middle of the night with
hyperventilating attacks like just like
fear like like this I can't even I don't
want to go there now cuz my skin kind of
gets crawly when I think into it but it
was like wow this eternal non-existence
thing yeah
and Wayne was where was i before I was
born exactly I was eternally
non-existent uh I mean even now I can
feel that my system kind of feel into
that fear as a child and so I said you
know let's let's check this thing out
and go to the course and see what what I
can discover and what I discovered was
less of the fear of or overcoming the
fear and more coming to grips with the
reality I was going to lose everything
that I loved yeah and the first thing
that hit me viscerally was my mom
because you can imagine as if I you know
she was your your your stability she was
the only thing that made she she
actually gave I don't must say my life
meaning so mom was the thing that made
life worth living feeling so when I went
to college and then I had that
experience I'd said I'm gonna write her
a letter I said oh I'm gonna write my
mom a letter like this is the moment and
we were everything was great there was
nothing that needed to be said because
there was a problem just like I really
want her to know how I feel yes I like
want to make sure that like everything I
have to say to her is said now and I
don't want to leave anything unsaid yes
so I wrote that letter I wrote it and
you have a copy of it yeah I have a copy
of it it's in the book yes it's in the
phone so I wrote that letter and I like
ran and caught the postman like I
remember it like like oh I remember
seeing him and like I want her to get
this letter really quick quick because I
just want to have that connection and I
want her to know how much she meant to
me I mean those to me at that time and I
she got the letter and then she left me
a voicemail mm-hmm and she just said
lovely letter thank you yes strangely or
quite interestingly I sent her my final
essay in the sociology of death class
which was basically essay 4 pager on the
death of somebody yes was in the letter
that she got additional to the Wow
actual letter
and then yes she went out that night it
was you know she would have gotten it
say six seven left the message and four
hours later she was hit and killed by a
drunk driver so that was that changed
life forever it was the same day same
day as few hours after she got after she
left your voicemail after she left the
voicemail
oh my god and you were 18 and I was 18
yeah totally dependent on love yes yes
even writing in the message I don't know
what I would do without your shoe yeah
yeah like reading that after having like
lost her even this many years later was
just crazy it's like wow like I wrote
that then and it was only you know hours
later that after I received a message
that that was true so this this
definitely spurred the who would you
write phenomenon but that's 30 years
yeah so so how you felt in that moment
of getting the we on our next image we
have the the Newton the newspaper here
yeah how did you discover that this even
happened and what did it feel I was had
a I was at a track meet because I was a
freshman walk-on at UC Irvine running
track and and out of the corner of my
eye I saw my brother and there was no
reason for him to be there he was just
there and I thought interesting I still
would jump in and I and I did see him go
and talk to the coach but I didn't
really you know register that it was
anything big and then and then we I
finished and then I went or was walking
with him there's a kind of a big field
to the parking lot and he and then it
was someone behind me and I turned
around to them and he said he they they
said yeah I'll see you later tonight
they said yeah I said shout it back yeah
I'll see you later tonight and my
brother said no you won't yeah and I
just kind of looked at him his face was
a little bit as you know what do you
mean no no no I'll see him later tonight
and he said no you won't mom was killed
last night in the car accident and then
that was like I can't express the
emotion at that time like I hit the
ground like convulsing sort of you know
when you asked yes thanks you lose
complete sync of emotion and rash like
it's no you're no longer you're no
longer in your body it was just like
every inhibition I'd have to
seen in any way was just non-existent so
it was it was dramatic feeling into it
has been hard let me I feel back into
that pain he just raw total raw that's
early for her she was like 45 or
something it's like a question I'm not
exactly sure oh she was I think maybe a
bit a 47 in that direction yeah and I
just I just that feeling of you
describing the moment of falling down
and just the feeling like you're not
even in your body just what what it what
it means to have a mom for 18 years and
then to the next moment and no she's
dead is that and whatever happens to
someone's soul when that occurs is yeah
that it's an explainable yeah with words
and even to put that feeling into
someone so for them to understand it
it's just that would almost be like
torture it's torture because if you're
living with that much pain and an in
general society wants to heal so no one
tends to sit with you in that pain
they're all trying to heal it somehow
and you know that becomes more annoying
than the pain itself because then you
almost have to put on the exterior that
I'm better than I actually am only so I
don't have to deal with your question
how are you are you good what's going on
you know if you had to have that
conversation a hundred times you just
I'm over it so you just Oh
it's there's this very strange sort of
balance between talking about trauma and
just bathing in trauma and so I think
talking about it and working our own
healing processes it's really important
and getting through it as quickly as
possible something that I think is
really important but I just know too
many times that we bathe in trauma and
that we just desire other people to hear
about us bathing in trauma and then it
just turns into and I'm never getting
out of it thing and so no matter what
the insane horrible feeling is that
happened how can we get through it
together can you get through it or me
get through so you spent a period of 20
years going through just depression and
sad feeling about yeah I would say you
know what happens is you feel the deep
dark pain and then you find coping
mechanisms to kind of shovel it down a
little bit more and a little bit more a
little bit more but underlying it all is
this unresolved pain yeah and and it
takes different shapes and forms and it
you know manifest itself in
relationships or just about any anything
that you know anything where you finally
say well there's this pattern that
happens over and over again and yeah
apparently I'm not improving anything
because the same thing happened the year
before in the year before that and that
was giving a parent to me I'm happy that
you caught that and what were you using
for your like pushing the pain away I
mean what I believe I was using cuz you
know I've lived in seven countries since
I left the US when I was twenty you were
using travel and to do the incredible
feeling that you get from exploring new
places yes world interesting because
then all that positive stimulus it was I
realized at some point I had to
emotionally commit suicide I had to say
that Andy is dead because I was I was
heading to dead anyways that I had to
say that Andy's dead and gone now what
does he want to do and then I just went
to an education abroad program and I
left to Australia yeah and I spent a
year and then I took a year off school
just to travel the world with a backpack
and then that just evolved to what
turned into a 28 year journey that
didn't bring me any time back home yeah
in fact the beauty of this trip like
really the almost overwhelming beauty is
that when I was 20 I left the pain and
now at 48 I'm coming back and actually
yeah I'm bringing the pain back and the
way you're doing it is is is actually I
think the best way to do it is you've
now created something that then teaches
other people about how to live
in just the place of distrait presence
just incredible presence incredible love
to this whole present moment like I want
to get these letters out I got addicted
to writing the last letters last night I
just kept going because it was so
fascinating and we're gonna show you
guys what this is like to write these
last letters yeah but okay so have we
should we talk about now the 10 years of
love coming to the last letter so 20
years I love to yeah yeah so now what
are we what happened in the last 10
years that brought you to okay I'm gonna
start the last letter and we have this
cool picture of the of a cartoon the
last letter honey yeah so this was the
that's the manifestation of one night
when I said this is now an event I'm no
longer treating that is me just driving
for 10,000 miles B I'm putting this
sticker on the side I've gotten good huh
I've gotten more people that take
pictures of me that with that sticker
then you could like take it again it's
hashtag inspire vulnerability yeah I
love that yeah because the whole the
whole thing is that the last letter is
just one way that one can inspire
vulnerability I'm really desiring that
people look at the bigger picture that
in sharing that last letter what I'm
actually doing it is inspiring others to
do the same yeah because I want to be an
example of what I want to model and
allow others to exhibit for others so
they can be a model and clearly it'll
grow only because people are living the
thing and that's what my real desire is
in this whole project and so let's go to
the next image this is exactly where you
have taken this yeah tell us about this
is in this is the consciousness hacking
group in San Francisco what was that
yeah it was an incredible group and we
had a I believe 45 or maybe even more
that night and this is just an example
of the sessions will always be broken
into three parts the first is me sharing
the life story and and actually just
creating space for people to connect to
their own emotion so I'll really just
share my story I don't really set rules
I don't really specify who you have to
write or what horse but I just give them
that space and they they fill it and you
know the things they come up with I mean
there's not a session I don't cry I mean
I think yeah I started last night
tearing all
oh my gosh it's such a beautiful process
yeah and and the beauty is is that in
the complete freedom of exploration to
everyone where they don't feel imposed
on they can step into the space that no
one's being forced anywhere yeah and
somehow the invitation is just just so
beautiful just having someone just
saying hey I'm welcoming you here you
know join me in the space for a while
and see how it feels without any burden
of needing to do anything or be anything
just yes just share that space a bit I
think this is the you know this is
probably a really good time to show
people what is actually being written
there because all right we have we have
you know we'll pull it well well if we
have Andy's website here is the last
letter comm and the link and the links
and the bio as well and when you get to
the last letter you know Ron you showing
the NDI yeah awesome so as you see on
the screen you got the last letter comm
and then when you reach the site and you
get to right here you see right my
letter so you click when you click on
write my letter you get sent to this
beautiful type form you guys definitely
got to use tight form it's so freaking
awesome yeah but so you know the last
letter coach this facilitator will help
you write the perfect letter to someone
you love make sure to answer the
questions the deep feeling of connection
to the person you are writing that last
sentence is so important with this
project because you're going to be
prompted with these questions and you
have to be and again inspire
vulnerability you have to be as
vulnerable as possible so let's go
through just a quick sample one so what
is your first name Allen who is the
first thing that person you're writing
to let's say I'm writing to Andy what's
the reason you're writing to Andy and I
can say I just realized and I like how
you give the you know you give a couple
of the options yeah I just realized I
need to be more vulnerable and then
enter what are you grateful to Andy for
you have been an incredible inspiration
to me opening up in the
to my family mmm and then what has any
specifically done for you when you look
at me to fully see me for who I am
beautiful and then what has this meant
to you this means that I can be myself
in the most emotional ways without
feeling bad about it and then what how
has Andy impacted your life when I look
at my life I feel like I've felt more
and then what are your favorite memories
I'll never forget our show together
mm-hmm and then what do you always
wanted to share with Andy this last
question super interesting because you
really get it getting them to stretch
into you know what's the most
challenging thing to say you got a
really you know really really you know
pull here and I you know I might I might
say like you know it's hard for me to
share that I wish I was there to help
you with those 20 years yeah and so you
know below you'll find your letter
please copy and paste us into an email
or go ahead and send it as an actual
lycra handwritten letter and so just
like that you know you take this and
then you copy it into an email and you
know here it is dear Andy I just realize
I need to be more vulnerable you have
been an incredible expression to be
opening up emotionally our family when
you look at me to fully see me for who I
am this means I could be myself in the
most emotional ways without feeling bad
about it when I look at my life I feel
like I felt more I'll never forget our
show together it's hard for me to share
that I wish I was there to help you with
those 20 years love Allen that right
there is and you can you can take it and
you can chop it up you can add another
sentence to it you can spate make
spacing throughout it it's just
and you can edit these questions you
know there's so much that we have yet to
brainstorm on because this is what I was
thinking of last night when I was
emailing you was just that oh wow
imagine cuz simulation we asked about
you know what are we gonna do about
robot ethics what are we gonna do about
geopolitics
what does it did some ocean you've ever
felt what's the most beautiful thing in
the world yeah you know all these
tougher questions and what would it look
like if people drafted up their answers
to these questions emotional vulnerable
scientific technological and
inspirational and then put it into these
these beautiful type forms that then
that then source these amazing letters
that they could then share on social
media or share with their beloved ones
this is I love it yeah love it yeah i
mean i i'd love i love that you used it
and actually got the value out of it
because of course that was where i saw
it and a lot of people copy and paste it
so i don't necessarily get to see the
results of their of their activities so
it's really great to see it here and oh
and you and then just at the very end
there's the finally what's your email
address and then you can say that you
know please feel free to use my
responses on this site in social media
or print or just be anonymous or just
don't use it and so you know i've i
clicked use it because i want to you
know i want to see that you know be yeah
and so just like that
so we wanted to walk you guys through
that so you thank you for that yeah holy
[ __ ] oh it's i I'm excited to send that
to you later yeah at event to not to and
and yeah there's a lot that you know we
just saw the example of when you were at
consciousness hacking and then there's
another example we have another image
after cautious is hacking to show and so
you know this is when you actually have
people handwriting it versus using it
digitally yeah big difference as well
yeah what I've seen is that that I I
don't force the handwriting I just have
pens and paper and I say let's let's
explore and some people just grab out
their computers and that's just fine but
what I've seen is there is clearly a
cognitive response to writing your
writing and your feet it's like it's
we've separated so much from the contact
of the emotion that have
the pen and paper is one step closer to
the actual feeling that we're
experiencing as we write and yeah I just
I've seen just incredible discovery so
what people come to me with at these
sessions is always it blows me away and
it never ceases to blow me away it's
it's yeah they're writing to the the
things that they've been in on their
minds for years and years earlier
they're just releasing it yeah just in
ways I would have never expected it to
go as far as it has gone which is you
know as I said I'm I'm crying and each
session because these people are like
they're it's almost like I'm the priest
and they're coming to the priest with
the confession and the confession is
I've suffered for 15 years and you've
given me this opportunity to connect to
that and just I'm grateful for that and
yes it's just such a gratitude for me
that I can be that for somebody else I
love it and we have a good example too
but I've really liked how you made it
you gave this really far example which
is like I've suffered for 50 years and
there's these other examples which are
like you know I just my communication
with my mom just hasn't been that great
or like I feel very disconnected from my
dad or you know or you know something
about my boyfriend or my girlfriend or
my boss or my close friend or whatever
and even that message even though it's
not as crazy traumatizing I still really
empowering for someone so there's this
whole range of whole range
yes and you know what what's interesting
about the paper is that then they still
have to go to the post office and set it
off but with the digital you have no
excuse because it's literally they're
done for you right there and all if
these put it into an email so that's
like no excuse this one someone could
still be like I don't want to say you
know I actually want people to write it
without even the necessity to send it
because in a weird way you know that
necessity actually boy cuts them back
from maybe sharing everything that they
need to get it off their chest that's a
good point so I really want people to
not even have that I had I had someone
in the session the co-ack come to me
Andy I'm scared if I send this that they
won't be able to receive it yeah and and
I was really clear
listen you write this for yourself
everything you need to say and
afterwards you decide what you want to
do it and he just started to smile like
wow I can really feel what's going on
and and he came to me afterwards and
just deeply grateful he was just hugged
me for a long time you really helped me
ground things that weren't weren't
weren't feeling comfortable I love that
it's you write the letter and you're not
you you don't even have to have the
forceful feeling of oh I have to send
this because then you can really unleash
in your full list but at the same time
it's like if you do promise yourself to
send the letter at least you can unleash
like maybe 25 or 50 percent and send it
so you can start the moving the boulder
yes yeah and the whole thing if you stay
an invitation
everything works effortlessly when you
start imposing people are gonna resist
because they're gonna say I know you
want something for me and actually I
just want to be there for people in love
and let them feel what I mean I get this
is when I can cry every time because in
the last session this guy looked at me
in the middle of the group and said to
me Andy why are you doing this like a
little bit you know like there must be a
reason a reason that's ulterior cuz no
one is this kind behind you and then I
looked at him and I said because I love
you and and we looked and he saw and he
understood and then there was another
woman in the same meeting says I don't
believe you Linda Terry just you know
and explained to her in the emotions
that when you've gone through so much
pain and you've had to find peace with
that pain then you see that pain and
everybody else yeah and you know there's
people out there just struggling to feel
loved without being told what to feel
how to feel what you need to do to heal
just be there in love it's the it's the
simplest thing and yet it's the hardest
thing because we all need and want to
solve everybody's
just to be there in love is like it's
it's it's the revolutionary thing that's
obvious but not done just being there in
love yeah yeah
love is stupid yes I know wrong I like
Ron back there yeah we're gonna have a
session at the end of this you'll have
it in the corner crying no we can just
go and do drugs this this man you you
know you bring it up again we have you
know we'll get to this example just that
it is this sort of new why is this such
a new thing is it because we became more
distance from each other with the
increases in like square footages of our
properties and the suburban eyes like
living environments and disconnected
from thy neighbors and like oh if I
don't love this person I can you just
divorce them and I don't you know that
all these different variables the social
media economy now these different
variables have maybe cost some of the
separation as well some of the close
Ernest you know depending on but they
help both in cases but but you know as
you bring this up that people want to
just be loved feel felt and feel like
they're part of the community but at the
same time this sort of like Buddhist
principle of like you know I don't need
your love and your I don't need to be
attached to the desire of you needing to
feel what I feel or understand me in
order for me to be in in order for me to
feel the Bliss of life so that's also
strange because it's part of Maslow's
hierarchy that you need to feel this
love yeah and but this Buddhist
principle is just like no just you know
you feel the Bliss you are divine and
it's just this it's crazy cuz there's so
many of these perceptions of weird I
mean I write about it quite a bit in the
book cuz you know in those seven
countries a lot of them were Eastern
countries so I lived in Japan for two
and in in Japan for two years you really
get to see an entirely different way to
view a life mmm you know there's family
there's heritage
there's reverence to something bigger
than yourself yes so the the Western
independence like getting somewhere with
a determined mind with success which
dominates a lot of just our culture is
then not necessarily balanced out with
the just peace with being and just
comfort with quiet
yeah and those two that that call it
that paradoxical relationship that if
you're strong on one and light on the
other are strong on one and let them you
know the other that you're not really
able to like embrace everything life can
offer it's not good my bad it's just
they're all government that's our timer
yeah our 15 minutes however I was
interesting I was feeling through my
body that that it was about to cover it
but it did come it was just a couple
seconds ago thank you Ron thank you sue
us so so this is very interesting that
you pick out these different cultures in
the way that cultures have a feeling of
something greater than themselves yeah
and they're a little more respect to
maybe the lineages and we were talking
just yesterday night we did an episode
of fried chicken where we talked about
which is around show where we talked a
lot about just this feeling of being
greater than something greater than just
my little tiny grain of sand which is
you know mother earth Gaia the land that
were on in you know but there have been
many groups of civilizations that have
lived for prior to us that I've just
paid lots more respect to the land and
they think generations in advance and
and
the way that they behave and the this
type of thinking again why are we losing
this type of thinking in many ways are
we are we have we lost some sort of
intellectual capacity to remember that
and well III I see it more and more the
beauty of being able to travel and live
in different places for extended times
gives you this alternate reality on the
world you you you adopt a different way
so I live in Amsterdam now in Amsterdam
it's a Calvinist Society so they're
Calvinists it's Elden so the Catholics
they spent a lot of money
the Calvin's were outside of the city
walls and I said your excesses are not
what we want so they basically live a
life that's full of more minimalism God
it's there's not there's not this
extravagance yes and and what's
interesting was when a Calvinist society
begins to grow then you see that there's
humility isn't very much ingrained in
the culture so if you're in a you could
almost tell a joke like three guys are
at a bar one's a you know in this case
if there's the American the American
will tell you this is what I've done I'm
really proud of all of my achievements
and then the Dutch person sitting next
to him is gonna say my god you know have
a little bit of humility right we're all
trying to work it out we've all done
greatness in our own ways so don't
elevate yourself so there's a very it's
a very interesting to be in both
societies and experience how drastically
different they are they are so
drastically different and yet very
similar of course because there's a
human experience we all know are very
similar but these little pan versus
option yeah yeah Japan you know Japan
has its own it's a universe difference
and even African versus Southeast Asia
and South America yes and the book by
the way is for me an effort to show how
through those six seven experiences in
my life each one shaped me to lose a
little bit more of this identity as I
began to see through myself yeah because
there's nothing better than being in
another culture and having that mirror
and then realizing that you've taken for
granted who you've
yeah you never thought that you became
anything you just thought but when you
were in a society that's so different
than what you are you begin to realize
oh that came from
yes I'm earlier moment you know and
letting go of a lot of that has been the
journey and basically the things that
I've written about in in the book yeah I
really love the example of just going to
somewhere new and realizing that wow
people here behave differently maybe I'm
not as humble as I thought yeah that's a
great example of humility is a great
example yeah that's a huge important
example and just maybe the feelings of
like the pace of life we talked about
the pace of life a lot yesterday and
yeah I mean in Japan you have also
really interesting that you don't
elevate yourself above your superior so
if you're at a college in Japan if
you're doing a PhD then in general you
can't write a paper that would disprove
what your professor had had written so
there's a lot of conformity only because
it would be considered impolite employee
to like suggest that maybe what you
wrote wasn't completely correct and it's
very fascinating and you take you know
you take the different examples here of
profound sort of bits that people let
you roll with on the inspiring
vulnerability share and this is this is
one of the most important ones to me
because my when I when I basically told
my wife what I was doing
I said Ronnie I'm gonna go take three
months off do a journey and experience
this and grow you know wasn't easy and
what she did was something that just
broke my heart she took out this paper
from her wallet and she said I want to
show you something
and then she said this is the paper my
mom gave to me when I left Indonesia to
travel to the Netherlands where she was
moving permanently yeah and she said
I've kept it in my wallet ever ever
since she gave it to me and I didn't
know that existed until that moment yeah
and then and she opened it up and it was
sort of you know one of these cute
papers and and basically a line on it
that she read to me and we both cried
with
there was the one that that's here is it
all the pain they cuts your heart save
it as a gift to make you stronger yeah
and when when when we read that together
it was just it was just connected us
back to you know the beauty of you know
why we're why she's what she is not with
me but we're together in this
this is Ronnie's mom that wrote this
Ronnie's mom wrote oh that's so good Ron
isn't this quote good
well yeah but why don't we have to come
in like so vulnerable to get our heart
broken or to experience pain to just
become stronger people I mean what's up
with that I know Ron when did you shut
down emotionally to love and acceptance
and all that stuff Amy I'm closed I knew
that [ __ ] wasn't gonna go good for me
well well we have time after the we have
time after the video I love to sit with
you for five minutes
yeah yeah let's do a fried chicken of it
I'll go direct it Ron will sit in this
[ __ ] I'm gonna hug him for five minutes
Ron posed that question again though
that was a question again my question
why is it that we have to become in so
vulnerable and to experience these the
you know to pain and trauma to to be
stronger number one but also to be more
loving and understanding you know so
yeah I'm answering the question as I as
a as I'm asking you well what do you
think that when you both think Ron
Woody's don't wait um I don't know maybe
maybe I wasn't so loving coming in maybe
you know even though I joke you know my
extent of love maybe maybe I needed to
you know feel the pain to just
understand just a little bit closer to
it to what love is is supposed to be
yeah yeah well but then again I also
appreciate the Frank Zappa song broken
hearts are for [ __ ] you know do you
gotta be strong so you don't allow
yourself to get your heart broken
yeah if you get your heart broken it's
kind of your own fault for you know
being so vulnerable and what does Edie's
take on that I love Ron Ron just
answered the question as well as I could
answer it
except he probably didn't he didn't
necessarily he saw if I may what I heard
is that you saw it as one of the other
and I believe it's both of the same same
time oh that's good yeah and I probably
all say I am the most irreverent person
that you might ever meet like basically
I just live laughing at everything that
I'm doing including the tears I am
laughing like you idiot
yeah like but those tears are also part
of me
so I let them go just like I laugh at
the guy who's crying I went to see mr.
Rogers won't you be my neighbor I don't
know if he's sorry I thought on the way
I started weeping before the man started
I was just it just brought me back to a
special time in my childhood where
watching mr. Rogers I had to keep it on
the DL and not let anybody see that I
was watching you know this this
beautiful human being yeah and and
really that those those tears were
joyous and I'm grateful for the love in
the heart of mr. Rogers yeah I was on
the airplane here and I watched that
movie and the stewardess had to bring me
like tissue because I was so
pathetically crying I couldn't I
couldn't like it wasn't even like one of
those sniffle cries it was just oh my
god so okay you guys just had a great
little dialogue there about how it's
it's this both this feeling of being
okay with being vulnerable and seeing
those cuts that came in to let them make
you stronger yeah but also the the the
true importance of being like hey that
thing that you think's a cut on my heart
you know I feel great I feel powerful
I'm good like I'm not I don't have now I
don't have that weakness you know yeah
that's that that's the problem that I've
seen it drives me crazy is the judgement
to emotion yeah it is emotion just let
it be let it be and don't attach to what
it means don't go Freud on it just let
it be
I mean there's a beauty to yelling and
screaming and crying and it's all there
so why pretend like it's not there but
don't necessarily then say oh that is me
it's just part of me that happens to be
present now and that's sort of that's
freedom and my and my experience when
I'm not able to be that then I'm stuck
yeah because then I'm holding an emotion
back and protecting or yeah so in in the
in reaction Iran I would say you are
totally right I do not want you to be
vulnerable nor should you do it but if
you see yourself holding yourself back
because you're scared or anxious then do
it only to learn the lesson that you can
learn by doing it that okay yeah this is
this has been really solid this right
here about you know we were we've been
touching on this in so many different
aspects of the nuance it's been so good
because it's not binary
it's very nuanced driven and that's what
we love doing you on the show and
unpacking vulnerability and inspiring
vulnerability this is this is this one's
really powerful I like to save it as a
gift to make you stronger and we have
another one tend to end with well I
think I have one that was really impose
this one yeah tell us about this one so
I mean what in my heart when I began the
journey there was always like I'm gonna
I know what's gonna happen I know I'm
gonna be coming into situations where
people wouldn't necessarily write or
connect with people unless they were
given space that I was hoping to create
that they would do that and there was an
individual that I met before the tour we
had our discussion and clearly he
understood what I was desiring was that
he be more vulnerable with the people
that had meant something to him and what
he
he it was coming up a Father's Day
didn't write a letter but he wrote the
text and basically he said happy
Father's Day I know you don't have any
kids but you've been one hell of a dad
love you Oh
talk soon so he sent that that message
it was before Father's Day and he didn't
get he said he didn't get a reply for
like two or three days and were having
matura that where it was in the mark
four days let's say and he said every
day he looked at his phone like when am
I gonna get them at like when am I gonna
get there because it meant so much to
him to write it and then he got the
thanks that means a lot to me I've tried
to give you the support which I wish I
had had yeah so that was the message he
sent to him and he said he cherished it
like it meant the most like the most
that he could have magically and then
and then in in in and of course in the
painful reality is that the day after he
sent this
he was bike riding he was 81 years old
and he was hit and killed the day after
he sent this text back to him Wow
so he said to me Andy I want to you know
share this with you because this person
was so special to me in that and I just
appreciate so much that I could send
this to them before they died not
knowing again damn you know that it
could happen the next moment they could
be gone and that you want to close these
loops man you're making me want to go in
close so many loops making loops like
these letters these frenzied urns are
gonna die I want to write a letter yeah
I have so many of these that I need to
write now holy cow yeah yeah
yeah you just didn't you just write your
you friend a letter last night yeah
three I wrote three last I'm probably
gonna write three more tonight I turn
into a meditative exercise every night
yes my love - yeah I would have I would
have so many people that that just are
like wow what's that haven't heard yeah
what happened Ally Betty reached out to
love I thought Alan was disconnecting
from people so he could focus his time
all of a sudden he's now he's full of
love and closing these loops and then
it's like if I get these messages I'm
like crap I hope I don't die please oh
wow and this same person by the way came
to a session and they wrote the last
letter to that person the one that they
wish they had to remember yeah yeah it
was just a beautiful it's beautiful to
be with him when they had that
opportunity yeah yeah so good so how
many how many of these do you get
submitted like a day well I mean what's
going on is that it's that that's been
the bigger challenge for me is cuz I I
didn't quite factor in that when you
write something that beautiful and that
vulnerable the last thing in the world
you're like let's publish it let's get
it out there so in essence I've been
asking people to take one or two
sentences that meant something to them
and send them to me so that I can like
use that to inspire others to do it I
really am hoping to create a movement
around this where the more people see
that they can allow themselves to be
vulnerable as others to do the same and
that's really why I'm doing this I love
it and I love it I love it I love it yes
yes and we're gonna increase
vulnerability on the planet together I
love it there's so many of us kind of
pursuing this but I love this this path
this path is a really important and easy
one I think it's fairly easy for people
to do that's the barrier of entry solo
and that's what makes it yeah I get
going with that vulnerability okay let's
ask you a couple quick questions okay as
we you know we come to an end on the
show we like to ask specific questions
that we ask our
yes so Andy I'm excited to hear your
thoughts about these I like that we look
at Ron for this Ron are you gonna
approve of these or not I get it I've
been I love it okay Andy do you think
we're alone in the cosmos no I just know
and I don't know why the question is
relevant in the one level because why
does it matter I mean if we take
ourselves so seriously then to some
degree it's almost like wow we are the
creators and in some way yes we are the
creators of our awareness of the world
but this is so much bigger than us that
it would be hard for me to like just
just say we're the ones you know okay
next question is do you think we're in a
simulation I know we're in a simulation
because if you look at your brain your
brain creates the reality it experiences
and it's using sensors that's using ears
eyes taste so it is a simulation that we
ourselves are basically in and to the
degree that we're aware of the
simulation is hopefully where
consciousness you like allows us that
possibility to expand beyond it but it's
not it's not easy it's a journey of
exploration self exploration see so you
you are have identified that that you
you you taking in sensory inputs that
are limited to whatever whatever times
we have data where you have that the
fact that we're simulating our
understanding of where we're at and
stuff that that in itself is a
simulation yeah okay and then do you
think that this reality that we live in
is being simulated at a grander scale
well imagine this we all live in a
shared projection mmm-hmm take you take
money for example yeah sure if money is
paper it's only paper it could lose its
value tomorrow and then we would be
confused as to how did we project value
onto something that's now worthless so
it is a shared projection that's just a
question of how conscious are we of that
projection and
how much does that define us without us
knowing it yeah that's the yes the
riddle that we all have to solve for
ourselves so as we guide more people to
objectively understanding that it is
just a shared hallucination and the
value of this or that you know we both
call that a glass you know are these
different things hmm okay
all right good answer good answer all
right Andy last question last question
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing the most beautiful thing it's
always hard with superlatives the most
and you know I would say being because
whenever I'm not being it's not
beautiful so being as a state is it on
or off on or off and being would be
defined by my capacity to fully let
myself be at peace with whatever is in a
given moment in time yes and to the
degree that that isn't there then then
it's not a good time or it's not as good
as it could be oh it's so interesting
cuz Jo Hudson was just on the show and
his answer was now yeah I was his answer
yeah beautiful thing the world now and I
was like wow well that would be and
that's what you that would be my answer
in another form of course it is your
answers are just right in that same form
except you know I really like the way
that you phrased yours being being at
peace with whatever is that moment in
the next moment just being at peace
because that that moment is so beautiful
and precious that all of those moments
are like the same moment in a way it's
like wow that's how it feels when I'm
when I'm looking at you in love and it
just there's like ass feeling it
overcomes you and your space you know it
just isn't there it's just this and that
you know what what is more beautiful
than that it's almost like there's some
sort of a vibration that when we are in
the you know fight or flight sort of
mode that it just the vibration so close
to us and then when we're in an open
vulnerable
this sort of heart and bodily energy is
just vibing outward and then you're
vibing inward and yes wool that's the
best that's so good this has been
amazing and thank you so much for
joining us thank you man oh this has
been such a blessing
thank you inspiring vulnerability let's
get more people inspiring vulnerability
let's get more people that care about
the sort of process of identifying what
is going on within themselves with their
loved ones writing to them this
beautiful process let's get more people
doing it links in the bio go and give it
a go try to like the book to be sure yes
and the last letter book as well along
with you know find that on last letter
comm along with the type form do them
both check them out
give this a go in your lives you need to
bring your honey love some chocolates
she needs some and she's not leaving the
house because of that letter you wrote
so keep that in mind it's getting
impressive ting chocolate to people it's
almost always an amazing idea much love
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
give us a comment below let us know your
thoughts how are you inspiring
vulnerability tell us about your
vulnerabilities we'll tell you about
ours let's have a community discussion
about this also huge thank you for Ron
our producer director thank you very
much for our show today also everyone do
not just consume this content go create
it go create with it go make with it go
build so make blogs make music make
videos make writing and make businesses
go create create create will have
powerful vulnerable discussions with
other people thank you everyone for
tuning in and we will see you soon
I'm gonna go hug Ron now
[Music]